l'équipe de la grande région de montréal
pour voir comment on vibrait à la coupe
du monde et en tant que besoin dans
l'impact de montréal l'impact de
montréal et boissons vous inviter à leur
match de mercredi à 11 juin normalement
là on sent que c'est devenu un sport
aussi montréal elle la coupe du monde on
disait c'est la 12 juin à l'université
vous états unis avec eux s'occupent
d'eux j'aimerais c'est que ça m'amène à
des bourses d'études dé commencer je
vous laisse encore un accident
ouais
à l'origine ça plaisait beaucoup
je m'appelle recul est dû qu ils étaient
trois deux voies sans y est j'ai
consommé shia la veine numéro 1 0
les comètes de brossac
alors vous avez vu des extraits donc de
ce concours amical qu'on avait lancé
huit équipes de la très grande région de
montréal et celle et commettre de
brossard oui qui ont remporté pas on a
vu que les mamans étaient aussi contente
que les les jeunes filles que les
joueuses justine boutet et la récompense
on le rappelle c'était que les joueurs
de l'impact allait s'entraîner avec les
joueurs ou joueuses de l'équipe gagnante
placé dans ce cas ci ce sont les joueurs
oui voilà patrice et c'est pas tous les
jours qu'on a la chance de fouler le
terrain soccer avec les joueurs avec des
joueurs professionnels et des joueurs
les joueurs de l'impact alors les faits
elles sont absolument étaient fébriles
avant que ça commence
le ch a arrêté l'entraînement du moment
pour pouvoir leur parler et on a fait
vous savez avant que avant que je
commence à parler aux filles on a fait
de cette activité là vraiment un
événement on organiser un barbecue ya le
maire d'ailleurs de brossard paul leduc
est venu faire un petit tour est venu
rencontrer les filles un peu plus tôt
alors les comètes de brossard ont
travaillé fort pour remporter ce
concours là et là aujourd'hui elles ont
un s'entraîne avec l'impact de montréal
alors j'ai mary bale et chats y en a
mais côté mary bale d'abord par mois de
l'expérience là sur le terrain avec les
ben si c'est vraiment ben je les vois
c'est comme on n'y croyait pas là ces
gens leurs règles et puis ça c'est
vraiment génial j'ai vraiment aimé ça
c'est une belle expérience qui va rester
longtemps dans la ma tête s'est pas
terminée parce qu'on voit derrière nous
plier vos coéquipières sont encore entre
et entraîné je vous promets autres vous
garder longtemps les faits saillants du
monde sait plus comment se déroule
entraîneur qui m'aident à fond on a fait
un petit échauffement puis là on est
allé faire des passes justes pour
s'échauffer puis après on fait un
exercice deux attaquants défenseurs ce
moment je pense que ça va bien l'appui
vraiment c'est une expérience vraiment
inoubliable dernière petite question
maribel si tu avais un conseil a demandé
à l'impact au joueur d'impact
aujourd'hui ce serait quoi
benjamin du conseil que j'aimerais avoir
ben surtout m'améliorer sur les points
faibles que j'ai dit je me souhaite
merci beaucoup les faits et
j'ai à ma gauche maintenant deux joueurs
de l'impact patrice bernier le capitaine
et wandrille lefevre et messieurs merci
d'être là et peut-être mais j'aimerais
savoir qu'est ce que vous vous souhaitez
que les filles retiennent de cette
expérience et de l'entraîneur retiennent
toutes les instructions de la dolly et
je pense d'eux les ballons assez
l'expérience je pense que le facteur de
pouvoir ils ont donné un gros effort
pouvoir être là pour gagner puis il a
une récompense d'avoir les joueurs de
l'impact de venir d'un entraînement
guy delahaye faut pas être gêné c'est ça
arrive pas souvent oui juste profiter la
totalité combat à participer plus
l'enjeu j'étais proche d'avoir cette
connexion avec les avec nous le que
c'est on ne sait pas un ou deux mondes
le monde professionnel et vendre elle
très rapidement il ya plusieurs joueuses
qui ont exprimé leur rêve devenir un
joueur professionnel de ça car ça serait
quoi ton conseil en quelques mois leur
donner un bon mon conseil c'est que au
final quand elle nous regarde faut que
faut qu'elle comprenne qu'on avait le
même âge à un moment donné qu'on était
au même niveau qu on a fait les mêmes
choses
donc c'est pas quelque chose qui est
inaccessible faut juste croire en soi et
travailler il n'y a pas de secret c'est
la même chose à l'école et c'est vrai
sur le terrain aussi il faut travailler
si beaucoup merci beaucoup alors on a
pris des notes seulement des filles vous
avez pris des notes russie voilà
patrice emballé c'est l'entraînement se
poursuivront leur travail et la passion
qui est là on la sent
merci je signe pour votre collaboration
cours de ceux de six rendez-vous qu'on a
eu au cours des dernières semaines